but do you think he crossed the line
I mean so I could see some people being
bothered by it for sure I mean yes he
definitely crossed sure
I don't think anything like you know
I don't know I mean here's the thing
it's it always depends on who's making
the charge of like
like who wants to cancel them like do
white people want to cancel them yeah
that's not really a thing yeah
I wasn't saying either way you know
these people can't cancel that you know
I mean like no you can't like who's who
wants to cancel that
yeah so I mean he definitely he
definitely had people in the comments
are saying off the rails and other
people are saying
uh isn't that a comedian's job that we
just laugh at the lines and yeah I think
just from a comedian perspective us
being comedians I think funny as long as
it's funny I think people can say
whatever they want on stage is a lot
it's funny and clearly a cautious
seasoned enough to make a situation like
this funny but what I hope is that young
Comics don't see this and assume that
just because they're at an open mic at a
coffee shop at 7 pm on a Tuesday
heckling the Barista like just because
someone at a show isn't laughing doesn't
then give you the right or the skill set
to be able to
comedically yell at this person Akash
can pull it off but I just don't want a
younger comic to see this and be like Oh
I'm that's me now I'm the yelling comic
I'm going viral on Tick Tock with seven
minutes of jokes that three of them are
actually funny that I stole off memes
from Reddit like
I'm cool with Akash doing this because
he can pull it off yes and what he did
was funny but I just don't want younger
Comics to see this and then think oh
well that's what comedy is now yeah no
that's a really good point and it needs
to be said and understood that a
seasoned comedian doesn't get people
disturbing him in the front of the show
you me like that doesn't happen at shows
like where someone in the front is
literally looking at their phone like
that's a that person problem like yeah
because it's funny enough to be like
have a good show even if you're not
laughing at all the jokes there's some
stuff You're gonna laugh at you know
what I mean because obviously the crowd
was into it yeah you could just tell
this guy was just not into it at all and
he was like that the whole show like it
wasn't just with Akash and Akash wait
until the end of his set it said 45
minutes in like he basically did his
headliner set and then went in on this
guy so he was still professional enough
to do his show gave the people what they
paid to see and then went in on this guy
he didn't derail the whole show and was
just like it's all about this guy now he
did his set and then had fun with this
guy in the situation yes I think that's
important you hear me like that's an
important factor to like figure out hey
this is not
I'm gonna at least do the thing that I
got paid for and then do the thing that
I feel afterwards because here's the
thing those people could have left but
they stayed for it yeah
and you know what's crazy a lot of the
times I don't know if this guy is an
example of this but the majority of
people like if you go to a show and
someone's just sitting there the whole
time staring at you a lot of the times
those are the people that come up to you
afterwards and are like wow that was
amazing thank you so much I needed that
like so many times I've had that happen
you know that is so true I think
sometimes we forget that people
sometimes
yes sometimes I've been trained on how
to laugh exteriorly you know what I mean
like we need you to laugh on the outside
you hear me like yeah yeah laugh on the
inside we needed outside voice laugh
yeah yeah yeah yeah we just don't know
or they like think it's not okay to
laugh or like they're just like I don't
know they're playing a part or whatever
it may be that's a really good point
I've seen people who literally did this
the whole show
and then came back to me after the show
man that joke about your dad it was
freaking hilarious yeah
but you didn't laugh though yeah exactly
and this guy in the Akash video was it
seemed like he was a little
condescending
um and like he was egging it on he was
an exception to this that we're talking
about but that little reading line not
okay yeah not I mean especially for like
the feature because the features are
gonna go in on you because that's not
his job yeah yeah I went in on somebody
like that the headliner would have a
problem with that because you're like
taken away from the show itself and then
you're losing your time on your feature
set but yeah that's yeah he was ecoted
on yes so that that's that's a good a
good consensus there that Comics watch
this and learn from how we handled it
but then don't go think you can just go
yell at an audience member for not
laughing and it's gonna kill
absolutely nuts
something